what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future
all right what's going on guys this is
Rob and am i recording I am recording
cool all right
Gordon keep this in I think it's funny
to put the little tidbits in there when
people are just kind of like Rob has no
idea what he's doing you don't even know
if he's recording what's going on guys
this is Rob and we are back with how to
kill superheroes ah because you guys
were a morbid Bunch and you guys love
seeing us kill superheroes I don't know
why we've killed so many so far I think
what we've killed something like 30
superheroes over the course of like the
last two years we've killed so many
different superheroes yeah dude how long
how long it just figures but this series
is going on for like a year and a half I
think maybe like a year something like
that well we've been doing it for a
while so we've gotten pretty good at
killing off superheroes but of course in
this video we are talking about dr.
Manhattan now of course dr. Manhattan is
really like the big talking point in DC
rebirth and a lot of you guys have asked
for his characters I'm like okay I mean
I guess we can you know if you guys
really want to see dr. Manhattan it is
kind of funny cuz I feel like we should
say a few words you know if we're gonna
kill them off but like what do you say
like you're standing at the funeral for
dr. Manhattan you're just kind of like
yeah he was blue walked around naked he
was weird kept saying something about
getting in tune with nature I have no
idea but he did make some good chili and
then everybody's like yeah some pretty
good chili above all of the guys who
don't know who may not be familiar with
dr. Manhattan he made his debut on
Watchmen by Alan Moore and Dave Gibbons
in 1986 and that was the only place that
he appeared up until 2012 when DC
launched a line of prequel comics that
almost every single Watchmen fan hated
that was called before Watchmen it
wasn't until DC rebirth launched in 2016
that dr. Manhattan was introduced into
the main DC Universe now dr. Manhattan
was created when nuclear physicist John
Osterman was trapped inside the test
area of an experiment that his team was
conducting on the removal of intrinsic
fields which are completely made-up but
they are essentially what holds human
beings together molecularly
now if the intrinsic field is removed
the human body completely disintegrates
which is exactly what happened to Jon
Osterman however where Jon Osterman was
originally presumed dead over the course
of the next several months he actually
reappears but this time he has blue skin
and more importantly he's naked that's
not true I mean he is naked but it's not
important that he's naked I don't know
why I said that's important but more
importantly he now has a set of
ridiculously crazy powers so following
his accident
dr. Manhattan can manipulate matter on a
subatomic level which basically allows
him to do pretty much anything he wants
I mean he can use this ability to not
only do impressive things like build a
fortress on Mars as well as an
atmosphere that allows human beings to
breathe air and grow himself to great
big huge sizes but he can also use it in
battle both defensively and offensively
now in terms of defense
dr. Manhattan creates a force field
around Silk Spectre - you know Lori just
spazzed the whatever her name is ah that
protects her from his falling fortress
so we can infer that he pretty much can
shield himself from any and all physical
damage by doing this any time he wishes
dr. Manhattan has also used his powers
offensively on several occasions as well
most notably spoiler alert for a
thirty-year old story he disintegrates
his former teammate war Shaq at the
conclusion of Watchmen now in addition
to this dr. Manhattan can teleport
himself or others 80 where he chooses
possesses telekinesis and can create
multiple copies of himself that can all
function independently and
simultaneously meaning that he can
literally be in multiple places at the
same time now as we come to the last of
dr. Manhattan's powers that we need to
consider in determining how he can be
killed I want to clear up a common
misconception about his character now a
lot of people believe that dr. Manhattan
is on mission but that isn't technically
correct omniscience refers to the
ability to know everything that is
knowable which dr. Manhattan can do
Batman does that what he can do however
is he can't observe his own past present
and future at the same time you guys
think I'm making fun of Batman I'm
serious like when he was in the Mobius
chair he was the god of knowledge he
knew everything about everything even
know that you knew the identities of the
three Joker's and then wouldn't tell us
we have--we've we've waited all this
time DC we waited all this time we want
to know what's going on with a tree two
three Joker's please for the love of God
give us the story about the three
Joker's I firmly believe one of them as
a comedian in Doomsday Clock but what
this means is that he can perceive uh
anything that has ever happened or will
happen strictly to him but if something
happens on the other side of the world
that had no effect on dr. Manhattan then
he simply wouldn't know it but it
doesn't really help us since any attempt
to kill him would by definition occur
within dr. Manhattan's timeline and so
he's going to be able to detect it
before it ever happens so it makes him
one of the most powerful carriage in the
DC universe there's even an argument
right now that he's the one that made
the DC Universe I don't know how you
kill a guy who created the entirety of a
universe and probably the multiverse
along with it I have no clue but if you
still need more convincing there has
even been evidence in support of this
idea since the launch of DC rebirth dr.
Manhattan easily vaporized pandora a
character who had single-handedly
defeated the ultra powerful seven deadly
sins and mr. Mixel pedelec an extremely
adept reality warper in his own right
acknowledged that his power pales in
comparison to dr. Manhattan's so I think
that it's fair to say that we're talking
about taking down one of the most
difficult characters to kill in the
entirety of the DC Universe so the
question is can it be done is it
possible to take down dr. Manhattan and
if so then how well I think the first
thing that we're gonna have to deal with
is the fact that dr. Manhattan is gonna
see any attempt on his life coming long
before it happens fortunately there is a
way to counteract this and the Watchmen
comics Ozymandias uses a tachyon
generator to negate Manhattan's ability
to perceive the future now tachyons are
particles that may or may not exist but
theoretically move faster than the speed
of light I'm pretty sure tachyons exists
in Star Trek I have no idea if they
exist in the real world I know what Star
Trek it's like engage the tachyon pulse
or something like that I don't know over
watching Star Trek The Next Generation
which was the only good Star Trek like
Deep Space 9 sucked until the Dominion
wars it was the most boring show ever
until the Dominion Wars and then like
the original Star Trek was never good
and then Star Trek Voyager was just a
show about the Borg that lasted like
seven seasons next generation is
definitely the best one only in season
three going forward though she is wanted
to were terrible can I also say that
like best of both worlds when Picard
gets turned into a Borg it's like the
best season finale ever like this season
ended with Picard being turned into a
Borg and like everybody was like no I
can't believe that it was it was super
cool it was pretty awesome like that's
like ending a season of Breaking Bad
with Walter White being shot in the head
and then just leaving it and then like
The Walking Dead when like supposedly
you know when like negan killed somebody
that was a terrible decision by AMC
anyway uh we
dress now that still leaves us to deal
with the fact that dr. Manhattan is
pretty much involve alarm and doesn't
require food water or air to survive
which basically makes him immortal since
he can manipulate matter he could
effectively undo any injury that we
could inflict furthermore it was one
state of the document Hatton had the
ability to turn a gun into steam and
bullets into mercury so any weapon we
try to attack him with can be
neutralized by his matter manipulation
now we do see one instance where dr.
Manhattan was harmed when he was
vaporized by Ozymandias toward the end
of Watchmen but he reformed himself once
again only this time it took a matter of
seconds instead of like a matter of
months so this does not leave us with a
lot of options but I can think of two
possible ways that dr. Manhattan can be
killed the first of these ways is really
more of a plot device than an actual
plant but since dr. Manhattan's
abilities are science-based
he potentially has a weakness against
magic as many science-based characters
do of course the one time we saw a
doctor man hadn't interact with a magic
user was when he vaporized Pandora so
magic is far from a surefire way to take
him down but if someone was able to cast
a spell on dr. Manhattan before he could
vaporize them then maybe it would do
something I predict we'll see this
happen in some fashion during Doomsday
Clock
and it probably won't work but like I
said we don't have a whole lot of
options but the other possibility that I
think might work would be to use
telepathy now if someone was a strong
enough telepath I think they could
actually alter Manhattan's brain so they
simply would not protect himself from
harm or reforming himself after being
vaporized well we have never seen dr.
Manhattan encounter a telepath and so we
don't really know with any certainty if
that would work we have seen dr.
Manhattan at least demonstrate inability
to be influenced psychologically by
Ozymandias to basically retreat to Mars
and ultimately go along with Ozymandias
as planned it's also important to point
out here that Ozymandias has no
telepathic powers or any powers
whatsoever so someone who does possess
telepathy could perhaps convince dr.
Manhattan not to reform himself if so he
would simply be vaporized just as he was
in the watchmen comic and then he would
never reform it's a long shot I know but
we're literally trying to kill dr.
Manhattan guys we could throw anything
out there we're gonna say things we
could say Batman with prep time we could
say like Superman 1 million comes back
and just punches them to death we could
say like anything like no answer we give
will work
there's no way to kill this guy no real
way to kill this guy he's crazy powerful
he's giant he's blue he's got an atom
symbol thing on his head I mean he was
designed to be a godly character so I
don't I don't know how you kill God I
don't have an answer to that question
guys I don't know but those are the only
two possibilities that I can come up
with that have even the slightest bit of
potential to take out dr. Manhattan
because any conventional means would
almost certainly fail since he would
literally just remove us from existence
by ripping our atoms apart and
scattering us through the winds I mean
yeah that's the only thing I'd be kind
of funny you know that'd be hilarious
like like Superman's like you're like
you know what dr. Manhattan this
conversation and going anywhere we gotta
we gotta get into a fight dr.
Manhattan's like nope and then ages
literally disperses Superman's atoms
across the spaceways that'd be hilarious
to me I don't know like I'm I need to
stop recording things at two o'clock in
the morning cuz I'm kind of all over the
place but if you guys are new here two
comments explain make sure you guys at
the sub button to become part of the Rob
core if you guys enjoyed this video make
sure you drop a like and I will catch
you all later purse
[Music]